نبدا باخر الاخبار الوارده من غلاف غزه
حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق دفعه
صاروخيه كبيره من قطاع غزه باتجاه انتي
فوت بالنقب الغربي واضاف ان سفرات الانذار
تدوي في كل بلدات غلاف غزه والنقب الغربي
من جهتها قالت مصادر اسرائيليه ان القصف
كان كثيفا وانطلقت الصواريخ من شمالي قطاع
غزه مستهدفه نحو 19 بلده في غلاف غزه والق
الغربي بما فيها مدينه
انتفا معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام اذا الياس اخر المشاهدات فيما
يتعلق بهذه الدفعه الكبيره من
الصواريخ هي دفعه هائله بالفعل كانت قبل
اقل من ربع ساعه واطلقت من تقريبا وسط
قطاع غزه باتجاه مدينه نتيفوت ومنطقه
النقب الغربي عشرات البلدات الاسرائيليه
كانت تحت وطاه هذا القصف الصاروخي الهائل
وال الكبير بعض الاعتراضات الصاروخيه من
جانب منظومه القبه الحديديه جرت فوق مدينه
نيتي فوت عشرات الصواريخ التي اطلقت ضمن
هذه الدفعه والتقديرات تشير الى ان نحو 20
صاروخا اطلق باتجاه نتيفوت والبلدات
الاسرائيليه المجاوره لها فيما يعرف
بالنقب ال الغربي بعض الصواريخ افلتت من
منظومه القبه الحديديه وسقطت حتى في داخل
مدينه نتيفوت
الان هنالك
صاروخ الان الان هنالك قصف يستهدف كما
يبدو المناطق التي اطلقت منها الصواريخ
باتجاه
اسرائيل اذا المروحيه الع عسكريه هذه من
نوع اباتشي التي تحوم في اجواء المنطقه
يبدو انها تستهدف منصه الصواريخ التي
اطلقت منها الصواريخ باتجاه منطقه نتيفوت
وكان قبل قليل هنالك قصف مدفعي شديد مياده
على نفس الموقع الذي اطلقت منه الصواريخ
باتجاه مدينه نتيفوت وكنت اشير الى ان بعض
الصواريخ افلتت حقيقه من ال القبه
الحديديه والان هنالك صاروخ اخر ايه
[موسيقى]
ينطلق اذا مياده كما تشاهدين صاروخ اخر
يطلق من هذه المروحيه العسكريه
باتجاه المواقع الوسطى المخيمات الوسطى
لقطاع غزه ويبدو ان هذا القصف يستهدف منصه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت دفعه صاروخيه هائله
باتجاه نيتي فوت والنقب الغربي وكنت اتحدث
عن ان بعض هذه الصواريخ افلتت من منظومه
القبه الحديديه واصابت مبنى في داخل مدينه
نيتي فوت الاسعاف الاسرائيلي يقول بانه
حتى هذه الساعه لم يتلقى ايه معلومات عن
وقوع اصابات في صفوف الاسرائيليين جراء
هذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه الكبيره والهائل حقيقه مياده
والتي تاتي بعد انسحاب الفرقه 36 من هذه
المنطقه يوم امس حيث كان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعلن انه اخرج هذه الفرقه التي تضم عده
الويه تابعه لسلاح المدرعات و بما في ذلك
لواء جولاني واحد من اهم وحدات النخبه
والويه النخبه في المشاه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي تم سحبها وبالتالي عادت
الصواريخ لتنطلق من جديد في هذه المواقع
التي عمل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي وكذلك هو
الحال في المناطق الشماليه كذلك بمعنى ان
واضح ان الجيش الاسرائيلي بخلاف ما تقول
بياناته لم ين جز شيئا واضحا في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه ولم يخضع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولم يخضع قدراتها الصاروخيه
على اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه المدن والبلدات
الاسرائيليه راينا بالامس انه بعد ساعات
قليله فقط من اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
سحب الفرقه 36 من شمال قطاع غزه كانت
هنالك دفعه صاروخيه كبيره كانت موجهه نحو
مدينه ديروت والبلدات الاسرائيليه
المجاوره لها 14 صاروخ وجهت باتجاه ديروت
ليله امس والان جاءت هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه
الهائله التي عادت لتذكرنا حقيقه مياده
بالايام الاولى للحرب حيث كانت الدفعات
الصاروخيه تنطلق دون توقف من داخل قطاع
غزه باتجاه المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى وهذا
بطبيعه الحال يثير علامات تساؤل واستفهام
كبيره لدى يعني كثير من المحللين
السياسيين والعسكريين عن جدوى هذه العمليه
وعن ما لم تحرزه حقيقه